solarstrom im all gewinnen das würde
viele probleme lösen jetzt meldet das us
verteidigungsministerium einen
durchbruch solarpaneele im orbit könnten
die sonnenenergie im all auffangen und
diese dann über einen mikrowellen laser
zur erde schicken ein erster test war
erfolgreich der traum gigantische
solarkraftwerke mal könnten so die
weltweiten energieprobleme der
menschheit ein für alle mal lösen oder
klicks und sayfuse dreimal pro woche
spannendes hans videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen billiger und unerschöpflicher
strom aus dem all klingt auf den ersten
blick nach science-fiction pur
doch die wissenschaft macht ernst und
die weltall gestützte solarenergie
befindet sich global in einer art
aufbruchstimmung und das aus gutem grund
denn machen wir uns nichts vor auch wenn
die technik rund um solaranlagen immer
besser wird und immer mehr haushalte und
e autos mit sauberer energie versorgen
können ein wesentlicher nachteil ist
nicht von der hand zu weisen
die abhängigkeit vom wetter die wolken
sorgen dafür dass die lichtstrahlen
wieder ins all reflektiert werden und so
kann an bedeckten tagen deutlich weniger
strom produziert werden als an
sommertagen ohne wolken am himmel und es
gibt einen weiteren nachteil denn der
anteil des kurzweiligen blauen lichts
wird durch die atmosphäre gestreut und
kann so bei weitem nicht mehr so gut
genutzt werden insgesamt sind es bis zu
60 prozent der sonnenenergie die durch
diese limitierenden faktoren verloren
gehen und so arbeiten forschungsteams
bereits seit einigen jahren intensiv
daran die sonnenenergie direkt aus dem
all zu ernten und genau das wäre die
lösung um den riesigen verluste zu
verhindern im orbit scheint die sonne
etwa acht mal intensiver als am erdboden
so erzeugt sie pro quadratmeter knapp
1400 watt und das zu jeder zeit hier
gibt es den wechsel von tag und nacht
nicht und zudem stören auch keine wolken
gewaltige sonnensegel an satelliten
könnten die energie dann zur erde
schicken entweder in form von
mikrowellen oder per laser auf der erde
könnte die energie dann in unsere
stromnetze eingespeist werden oder aber
in anderer energieträger überführt
werden eine andere idee handelt von
einem wärmekraftwerk auf dem mond an
vorschlägen zur energiegewinnung im
allem mangelt es jedenfalls nicht ist es
tatsächlich nur eine frage der zeit bis
wir menschen und so mit sauberer energie
versorgen können der amerikanische
fernsehsender cnn berichtet jetzt von
einem spannenden erfolg des
us-verteidigungsministeriums des
pentagons den arbeiten auch die
fachleute des pentagons daran diese
vision zu verwirklichen vor etwa einem
jahr im mai 2020 hatten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dazu ein programm mit der hilfe einer
drohne in eine niedrige umlaufbahn
geschossen pram steht für photovoltaik
radio frequency interna modul konkret
sollen solarpaneele im orbit die energie
der sonne auffangen und dann über einen
mikrowellen leser zur erde schicken die
idee energie im weltraum zu gewinnen ist
nicht 1941 hatte der bekannte ist
science fiction autor und biochemiker
isaac asimov über diese vision
geschrieben doch bisher gab es vor allem
zwei probleme bei den technischen
entwürfen zum einen die gigantischen
kosten und zum anderen die technischen
herausforderungen so beispielsweise auch
bei der idee des ex nasa mitarbeiter
john menkens sein system mit dem namen
sps alpha besteht aus einem riesigen
gebilde in form eines trichters
zehntausende dünne spiegel
die einzelnen steuerbar wären könnten
das sonnenlicht auf die solarzellen an
der satelliten rückseite lenken
nach den angaben von john menkens selbst
könnten so dutzende bis tausende
megawatt energie mit einem
mikrowellenstrahlung zur erde geschickt
werden auf der erde konnte diese art der
energieübertragung tatsächlich schon
getestet werden und zwar mit erfolg doch
bislang klappte das nur über kurze
distanzen im jahr 2008 gelang es
fachleuten beispielsweise 20 watt
solarstrom zu verschicken per mikrowelle
über knapp 150 kilometer über 500 meter
konnten bereits zehn kilowatt übertragen
werden dieser drahtlose energietransfer
beruht übrigens auf den ideen von nikola
tesla auch japan hat in diesem bereich
große pläne
die japanische weltraumbehörde jaxa
forscht bereits seit vielen jahren an
solchen projekten strom aus dem weltall
zu ernten bis zum jahr 2030 möchte japan
ein photovoltaik kraftwerk mit einer
leistung im gigawatt bereich auf einer
geostationären umlaufbahn im all
positionieren auch hier soll der
sonnenstrom dann in form von
energiereichen mikrowellen
der laser zur erde gelangen beteiligt
sind einige bekannte japanische firmen
wie etwa mitsubishi und folio zu der
plan sieht wie folgt aus zahlreiche
photovoltaik elemente werden in einem
ersten schritt ins all transportiert
dort werden sie dann zur riesigen
solaris in quadratkilometer größe
zusammengesetzt laser und energiereichen
mikrowellen sollen den sonnenstrom dann
auf die erde bringen
die empfangsantennen auf der erde
könnten auf schwimm plattform platziert
werden die mehr oder auf gewässern im
landesinneren schwimmen dazu heißt es
vom mitsubishi da die solarenergie
sauber und unerschöpflich ist glauben
wir dass wir mit dem space solar power
system ein beitrag zur überwindung der
energie engpässe auf der erde und der
klimaerwärmung leisten können am anfang
ist 100 kilowatt demonstrations- system
geplant später soll dann an zehn
megawatt pilot systeme entstehen
langfristig angedacht ist ein 1 gigawatt
system gigantische solarkraftwerke im
all also doch davon sind wir noch
meilenweit entfernt die fachleute des
pentagons haben bereits die ersten test
ihres projektes abgeschlossen
im mai des vergangenen jahres 2020
hatten sie ein gramm also ein
photovoltaik radio frequency antenna
motto mit hilfe der unbemannten drohne
x-37b in eine niedrige umlaufbahn
geschossen
diese drohne mit dem solarpanel umrundet
die erde im 90 minuten takt das ziel die
sonnenenergie über solarpaneele im orbit
auffangen und diese energie dann über
einen mikrowellen leser zur erde zu
schießen dieser kann besser als die
sonnenstrahlen die wolkendecke
durchdringend laut einem cnn-bericht
lief der erste test mit einem solarmodul
in der größe eines pizza kartons dieses
wäre demnach bereits jetzt in der lage
zehn watt energie für die übertragung
zur erde zu produzieren damit könnte ein
tablet mit energie versorgt werden 10
watt das reißt allen erstmal nicht
gerade vom hocker doch die fachleute vom
us verteidigungsministerium sind vom
potenzial dieser idee überzeugt denn das
modul lässt sich erweitern konkret
bedeutet das dass satelliten mit großen
flächen in der theorie dann sogar
größere städte mit strom versorgen
können möglicherweise könnten sie dann
sogar die kraftwerke auf der erde
übertrumpfen zu den angedachten weltraum
solarkraftwerken sagt einer der
projektleiter am pentagon paul jaffe im
interview mit cnn
es könnte zu einem der größten
stromnetze der erde beitragen
der einzigartige vorteil gehen die
solarstrom satelliten gegenüber jeder
anderen energiequelle haben ist diese
globale übertragbarkeit man kann strom
nach chicago schicken und einen
sekundenbruchteil später wenn nötig
stattdessen nach london oder brasilien
heißt also im klartext die satelliten
könnten sich in kürzester zeit neu
orientieren und somit auch auf der erde
alle möglichen region mit sauberem strom
beliefern ganz egal wie gut oder
schlecht die infrastruktur vor ort ist
dazu kommt auch stromausfälle auf der
erde könnten so aufgefangen werden
selbst naturkatastrophen würden der
stromlieferung aus dem all nicht im wege
stehen und noch viel mehr wäre so
möglich beispielsweise kommerzielle
elektrische flugzeuge die so durchgehend
mit energie versorgt werden könnten die
akkus bräuchte man dann wenn überhaupt
nur noch für start und landung das alles
wäre natürlich auch für die klimakrise
ein riesiger hoffnungsschimmer im
aktuellen experiment ging es vor allem
um die temperatur der elektronik die ja
während der runde um die erde abkühlt
wenn die hälfte der zeit verbringt die
drohne bei ihrem rundflug in der
dunkelheit so wurde eine art heizung
getestet und versucht brand damit auf
einer konstanten temperatur warm zu
halten in den nächsten schritten soll es
vor allem um die vergrößerung der fläche
gehen so könnten dann mehr mikrowellen
erzeugt werden um die energie in
richtung der erde zu schicken der
direktor der international electric
company in cash hatte in einem interview
mit wired gesagt dass die weltall
basierte solarenergie schon bald die
günstigste saubere energiequelle werden
könnte
denn dadurch dass immer weiter
nachgeliefert werden würde würde sich ja
auch das speicherproblem in luft
auflösen doch eine sache darf bei diesen
ambitionen nicht vergessen werden denn
abseits der umwelt politischen
ambitionen steckt auch ein großes
militärisches interesse dahinter
klar denn mit hilfe der unbegrenzten
energie aus dem all könnten
beispielsweise unbemannte drohnen über
jahre hinweg über feindliche gebiete
preisen
das us verteidigungsministerium hält die
details des projektes deshalb jedenfalls
geheim und auch die langfristigen pläne
die mit der technologie verfolgt werden
das einzige das fest steht heute oder
morgen wird uns die pram technologie
keinen sauberen strom aus dem all
besorgen können die fachleute gehen
davon aus dass die kosten für die
weltraum hardware möglicherweise in etwa
zehn jahren sinken können
die große frage die weiterhin offen ist
laut und außerdem wie kann verhindert
werden dass auf dem langen weg vom orbit
zur erde durch die atmosphäre
der hauptteil der energie verloren geht
dazu kommen weitere herausforderungen
die diese idee der energiegewinnung im
all erschweren zum einen die bedingungen
im weltraum wie beispielsweise die harte
strahlung der sonne auch der
weltraummüll würde den solarpanelen
gefährlich werden und so ist fraglich ob
sich ihr einsatz wirtschaftlich bei
einer solchen und möglicherweise in
kurzen lebensdauer überhaupt lohnen
würde
denn klar ist der orbit ist heutzutage
schon komplett überfüllt wie könnten die
sonnen satelliten die energie mit
mikrowellen übertragen ohne dass dies
beschränkungen für die anderen
satelliten bedeuten würde
denn diese müssten sicherlich abstand
halten und das müsste ja zunächst mit
betreibern und genehmigungsbehörden
geklärt werden fragen über fragen
auch was den weltraummüll betrifft
weltraum müllabfuhr könnte katastrophe
verhindern
kessler syndrom anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren verspricht ist mehr und
klicks um seine user natürlich
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran